[Musique]
l'ouvragé était pression' à le nouveau
pont champlain n'est plus une idée mais
une réalité
31 des 37 chevêtres sont déjà en place
en fait 80 % des travaux sont complétés
et le plus délicat reste à faire
terminez d'assembler la section à aube a
publiquement
on insiste l'objectif de décembre
prochain est toujours atteignable
dernière je n'ai bonjour bonjour on est
haut un peu au sens de la fourmilière
d'avant vous dit
croyez moi ça va être prêt je crois en
décembre prochain va rouler sur l'autre
actuellement l'objectif est de livrer le
pont ouvert la circulation pour le 21
décembre 2008 un défi aussi mais ça
prend absolument le secteur il reste
quand même beaucoup de travail à faire
absolument il reste beaucoup à faire
qu'on a fait
dans la période des fêtes l'année passée
on ne tient pas de recul à la gare de
l'ensemble du projet on a fixé les
objectifs réalistes et atteignables pour
chacun des équipes de compression sur
chantier et puis on se développer un
plan de match pour y arriver en décembre
2018 main d'oeuvre en temps de pénurie
de main-d'oeuvre partout au québec vous
vous n'avez pas de problème à les
chercher
tous ces travailleurs loeb j'en avais
assez suffisamment sésame en à 1400
travailleurs sur chantilly et on n'a
jamais eu aucune difficulté à trouver
des travailleurs
c'est un grand projet est un grand
projet de société un projet existant les
travailleurs sont au rendez vous l'autre
question que les gens se posent c'est
est ce qu'il va durer plus longtemps que
l'autre au chant plaît parce que l'autre
pont amont rage la primaube tout c'est
normal la question la réponse est
absolument sinon sinon ça peut aussi
entrer deux mois donc on
durée de vie minimum de 125,1 sur le
nouveau pont champlain donc sans ça
passe parfois par une qualité au niveau
de la conception de la fabrication des
pièces de la construction chance sur
chantier est aussi des matériaux donne
un exemple toute l'armature dans les
dalles le tablier à surface de roulement
nouveau pont c'est de l'acier inoxydable
on n'aurait jamais pensé soit ya 50 ans
installé ça ça c'est qu'on trouve pas
vraiment compris dans les riches
travaillent qui comme la pièce de
résistance le gros des heures de travail
et pas dans l'installation c'est dans la
fabrication la fabrication sépia ça
s'est fait en espagne
richard veille de l'arrivée son chantier
en 2 v pour faire le w tag arrive sur
chantier ces raids sont beaucoup plus
simples que le groupe de négoce de gros
blocs lego effectivement gogo qu'on
installe court-bouillon on comprend là
la tension
safran continue de glee l'essentiel des
heures travaillées au chou weight
prépare or chance et ça c'est la
stratégie construction du projet 1 c'est
vraiment le dire on a quarante deux mois
pour livrer le projet c'est un
échéancier qui est très exigeant
comment est ce qu'on arrive à livrer en
42 morts mais faut prendre les gens de
travailler ce projet et les exporter
alors à la création
on est sur des approches ou hertz
c'est vraiment très beau marin est censé
bien sûr pour la portion sur la jetée
ouest
c'est là qu'on comprend que l'hiver le
prix passe cette fois je dirais qu'on a
des 1400 travailleurs exceptionnelle sur
chance et ils travaillent dans des
conditions difficiles en hauteur au
froid à la pluie et le vin est ce que
vous êtes un peu à charlie par c
qu'on revienne tout temps sur le délai
sur l'échangé décembre décembre de sa
commande et vous dis tu le regardes 6
janvier ce sera janvier s'inscrit
comprenez vous
oui non sens que quand on a
soumissionner pour le projet ont
conservé très bien que l'échéancier
le plus grand défi qui attend on sait
exactement quand on va en partir plus on
est rendu à six mois de la ligne
d'arrivée la semaine prochaine et on
voit ce qu'il a à faire et on se dit oui
on est capable de finir atteint le
projet libéré ouvrir le feu en
circulation des 110 minutes
est-ce que ça va être facile absolument
faux trois personnes issues d'un projet
qui va équiper dire que c'est facile
mais l'objectivité en vue et est
absolument réalisable grâce envoie sur
le tablier du nouveau pont champlain
d'approché pour ça vous êtes le premier
média que sa capacité là
waouh presque à la hauteur de ta bille
on va très très bien les gens les blocs
de béton les segments des piles
après on a le choix va être vous voyez
un v qui est là un autre vie et ses
poutres la gigantesque ça ça a été
construit en espagne
non non tout mes coups de coeur sortie
québécois les six importe qu'elles sont
du projet le plus gros contrat de sous
traitance dans le projet de donner au
groupe canam nova ou le train va passer
ou le train de passer au centre à la
droite
parce qu'ici on est dans les corridors
qu'on appelle en direction sud
donc les trois voies de circulation va
trois voix plus une quatrième voie qui
votent un accotement donc y va d'une
bonification par rapport au prix actuel
et au centre un corridor complètement
séparée pour le transport collectif pour
le réseau express métropolitains donc on
livre le pont en décembre 2018 après
l'entrepreneur que gagner le projet du
real vont venir bâtir le réseau du rem
sur le credo centrale et voies cyclables
aussi voies cyclables donc on a une
pièce qu'on appelle multifonctionnel
donc l'attitude du fonctionnaire aller
sur le tablier en direction au nord de
brossard va le centre-ville à
l'extérieur en porte à faux
donc cette piste multifonctionnelle va
permettre la circulation en vélo dans
les deux directions et aussi
un piste pds et 4 belvédère en cours de
route qui vous permet d'avoir une vue
superbe sur le centre-ville de montréal
vous avez tout fait ça qu'est ce qui
reste comme des fils parce que poser vos
tabliers c'est parce que plus compliqué
j'imagine la pause et des dalles
établissez du volume on a plus de 9600
dalle était bien posée mais c'est quand
même un travail très répétitif pas très
compliqué donc c'est du volume
donc on doit terminer les derniers choix
va être installé en reste si ça va être
installé sur 30 irp
il nous reste à installer à peu près 50%
dépôt de questions
la paix il nous reste un solide à
l'établi donc c'est du travail qui met
dedans on doit la répétition de la
production le grand défi sur chantier
qui demeure c'est plutôt du côté du pont
à haubans ou longues rafales à la grande
traversée de la voie maritime du saint
laurent
le grand défi c'est vraiment le combat
l'eau est un facteur qui complique
évidemment l'assemblage du pont tout une
chorégraphie sur un fleuve à haut débit
serge letarte est l'un des capitaines de
ses nombreuses barge
on y passe pour ces points évidemment la
présence de ces bateaux là c'est
important dans la construction mais
c'est essentiel c'est un des liens les
plus essentiels de se dire est de 2 to
le pont ça se corse hulot ça qu'on doit
donner le service faut emmener les gens
travaillent et on a à peu près 40 2
barges différentes 21 pilier à l'eau on
doit transporter tout ce monde là
du matin au soir date à quoi votre défi
lé courant ah oui le cours est sénateur
ici au pays le 21 le courant nous
provient de l'île des soeurs
tandis que du côté brossard béni nous
provient de brossard que ça s'en vont en
entonnoir alors les plus basses qu'on a
ici on appelle ça le cimetière c'est le
coût est tranquille lorsque les vars son
port en action on les envoie l'eau
tranquille on a les briques du courant
êtes vous fier d'avoir fait partie de ce
projet là oui ça c'est une fierté qui
est et ça se mesure pour ces deux puis
je pense tout le monde s'est partagé par
tout le monde ce chantier ont construit
quand même un projet qui va laisser sa
marque
merci grand plaisir mais ça vous aux 270
m le pilier principal sera plus grand
que le mode du stade olympique le seul
pont de cette ampleur avec un seul
pilier ou passez les au bain de 60 cm de
diamètre
c'est ici que se joue la date de
livraison
[Musique]
ce jeune et on parlait de d'assemblage
tout à l'heure chassez les plus gros
morceaux assemblée oui ce convoi
l'arrière ici ce qu'on appelle un but ce
soir c'est comme une tranche complète du
pont donc c'est vraiment 60 mètres de
large par 12 mike points 5 ans lax
dupont comme tel et cette pièce là en
soi même plus de 850 à maîtriser
l'anglais les principes et si vraiment
c'est de dire on assemble cette tranche
de prolos au complet au sol et on vit la
levée d'un coup donc on a des
équipements de levage hyper spécialisés
qui ont été conçus et fabriqués
spécifiquement pour le projet dont on
parle du sol on lève sous le tablier du
pont et avec un système de rails sur
crémaillère on prend la pièce et on la
transe lattes jusqu'au bout du fléau de
la travée principale rendu au bout du
fléau la lève en place et on revient
sans c'est mal la boulonnerie vais vous
résumer ça en trois phrases technique
c'était le gros défi mais le plus grand
défi technique du projet c'était
vraiment
la construction de la travée principale
ces familles vous soir là on en a 15 à
installer trois des autres complétive
4ème commence demain et on doit terminer
sa essentiellement pour la fin du mois
d'octobre
en cours de route dont c'était parce
qu'on aura des défis a terminé à temps
donc en trot dont vont maintenant
installé certaines de ces pièces là à
partir de la rive sud
pourquoi parce que on est arrivé en
décembre a dépassé on a pris du recul on
se dit si on veut finir en décembre 2018
avec ce qu'on fait présentement on voit
du trot va finir en décembre de mes 18
ans que l'on nous dit travaillons à
partir du principal vers la rive-sud mes
plats sont au-dessous des pièces à
partir de la rive sud en allant vers le
pion pense pas donc ça ce qu'on appelle
des méthodes alternatives de
constitution qu'on a développé en deux
files pour être capable de s'ajuster la
réalité du projet frédéric guitare en a
vu d'autres le nouveau gros champlain le
fascine et l'exaspère parfois il est
responsable de la partie des haubans
n'avait fait ailleurs dépens oui oui
effectivement c'est le plus compliqué
c'est un conte très compliqué oui
absolument très très très compliqué dans
un échéancier très serré mais c'est très
c'est très compliqué oui parce que l'
architecture parce que oui pour les
contraintes architecturales pour le fait
que le pont est très très large et 1 d
un pont qui fait 60 mètres de large ce
qui est quand même assez unique
en fait je pense quand même c'est
probablement un des plus larges pont à
haubans jamais construit au monde il
faudrait vérifier mais je pense que
c'est un des plus larges donc la
structure travaille et sollicité non
seulement dans le sens longitudinal
méritera voilà il est sollicité aussi
dans le sens transversal ce qui crée
énormément de soucis afin de pas de
souci de problèmes à résoudre on ait
l'air heureux que c'est quelque chose
qui vous mettez ça c'est plus beau
métier du monde et c'est une passion il
faut tous les galas sont passionnés de
l'ingénieur aux manoeuvres en passant
par les monteurs les menuisiers tout le
monde il ya une émulation et puis là
légal il voit que ça marche
au début je pense qu'elle a un paquet
qui avaient des doutes ils compris nous
d'ailleurs
mais maintenant maintenant on sait que
tout marche donc on est dans une phase
de production et on est dans une phase
où on essaie de gratter la demi-journée
leur en intervertissant de deux
opérations en optimisant absolument
toutes les phases de travail on prend de
la vitesse parce qu'on a une courbe
d'apprentissage qui est très difficile
parce que le travail et munich n'a
jamais été fait avant est très compliqué
et puis faut faire attention absolument
pour vous donner une idée quand on lève
le segment ici on l'a vu 850 tonnes 60
mètres de large 12 mètres cinquante de
long et on a 15 mm de tolérance pour que
les groupies d'aider des pattes de
fixation rentrent parfaitement aux
ombres a voulu bonne chance merci bien
allez on va salut et aubin c'est ce qui
va faire que ça va être ma gesture web
ainsi c'est vraiment
l'élément signature du projet
quand on fait des études techniques et
architecturaux en début de projet en
avant projet il y avait un désir de
créer une porte d'entrée emblématique va
à la région de montréal donc le pont
quand white s'est pas entraîné en très
emblématique à partir de la rive sud
lorsque tout était en place pour qu'il
soit beau dès le départ les lumières est
ce que le pont sera intelligent ou sait
ce qu'est une technologie autres ce
qu'ils sont probables pas terminée en
décembre 2018 entre hausses et des
notions comme l'éclairage architectural
qui sont pas nécessaires à l'opération
sécuritaire du pont donc on ouvre le
pont à la circulation en décembre 2018
mais il ya des travaux qui vont
continuer en 2019 jeu sera whaou est ce
que ce sera un peu comme peut-être pas
comme le pont jacques-cartier pas comme
le pont jacques cartier il va avoir un
éclairage architectural sur le puits le
principal et sur les poutres de rive
dans du corridor nord et sud du pont et
l'éclairage architectural sur les
poutres de rive du 3 points 4 km va être
modulable et avec des différentes
couleurs
donc lorsque le canadien va gagner la
coupe stanley en juin 2019 on va
remettre le bleu blanc rouge du canadien
sont à nouveau là votre contrat aussi
non c'est un saint c'est un souhait
personnel est ce que on aurait pu tout
faire ça au québec où c'est illusoire
jeu quand je regarde l'ensemble du
projet mais 400 travailleurs québécois
il ya un milliard de contrôle qui a été
octroyée sur chantier à nos fournisseurs
75% ont été octroyés à des compagnies
québécoises
donc c'est un moteur pour l'économie
québécoise la construction du nouveau
pont champlain
j'imagine que vous entrevoyez le jour où
vous allez allez vous le faire à pied ou
en auto quand même moi je suis un
cycliste un cycliste tous les jours donc
grande fierté l'eau on le 21 décembre
serait un peu rohff en vélo mais l'idée
c'est de passer son nouveau pont
champlain en vélo ça aurait été vraiment
l'apogée pour moi ce projet on va suivre
le calendrier bien sûr merci beaucoup
plaisir